[Music]
we are back and we're talking eating
around the holidays now here's the the
deal there's always um ideas like YOLO
like bro you deserve it you've worked
hard this year eat everything and also
there's the other side which is the you
never stop grinding 24/7 365 I don't
care what day it is no celebration you
put the cookie down and there's guys
like me who are like
what what I like pumpkin pie and I like
turkey and I like lots and lots of candy
I don't know what to do so I'm calling
one of the smartest men on planet Earth
when it comes to nutrition science my
great friend Dr Lane Norton is here to
talk us all through eating around the
holidays what's up
Lane what's going on John how you doing
buddy dude I'm doing great thanks for
stepping out of your uh Beefcake 2000
training session to talk with us
man well I I left the deadlift B I'm
gonna go pick it right back up no
worries left the deadlift bar you know
who said that today nobody but Lane
Norton
only probably I am
unique you know what I think that's
gonna be on your Tombstone Lane Norton
he was unique just kidding um if it's if
nothing else brother no it's going to be
amazing father and a guy who helped
Millions millions of people Chang their
life me being one of them man U hey
thanks for coming on can you um dude
just I need some No Nonsense just
straight to it mothers and fathers who
are not in like the yo bro not in the
nutrition space family sitting around
the table over Thanksgiving and into at
we're post Thanksgiving by the time the
show comes out into the Christmas
holidays there's gifts there's cookies
there's holiday parties there's all the
stuff can you give us some some sort of
Common Sense approach for navigating
eating around the
holidays yeah so I think you know you
kind of touched on it earlier there's
there's like two spectrums right on on
one hand you've got hey you know one m
is not going to hurt you enjoy it don't
worry about it have whatever and outside
Spectrum you've got um you know grind
247 you know so where in between these
spectrums you fall kind of depends on
like you know what's your goal what what
do you want to get out of this um I you
know I'm not a feelings based person
when it comes to this stuff I'm very
data driven and so you know on the one
side when people people who say holiday
eating is in ulous and don't worry about
it that's actually just not supported by
the data um if we look at the amount of
weight people gain during adulthood per
year any depending on the study you look
at anywhere from 50 to 90% of that comes
in the six weeks from the end of
November to the beginning of January
which is what a holidays Lane don't
don't say that okay hold on real quick
can you talk can you talk directly into
your phone
dude yeah sure so oh perfect okay hold
on I need you to stop saying what you're
saying because what you're saying is I
can do really good for most of the year
and just kind of get off the rails
between uh October and Christmas and the
data says that's where most adults gain
most of their weight on an annual
basis that is correct so anywhere from
50 to 90% And the research suggests that
they don't they don't really compensate
the rest of the year most people kind of
maintain the rest rest of the year and
the date is actually worse for people
who are overweight or obese they tend to
gain even more weight during the
holidays and so like obviously you know
if you can just Mt I want to tell you if
you just maintain during the holidays
you're kind of ahead of the game um and
I think that should be the goal for for
a lot of people not trying to like lose
fat during the holidays but just
focusing on like healthy m
um but there's a lot of barriers in the
way the first off is if we look at the
food that's eaten during the holidays uh
s like in data in the studies it is
actually more calorie dense than the
food we normally consume so you're
you're getting more energy per you know
weight of food um and then if we look at
the data around eating in groups what's
really fascinating is when people eat by
themselves they eat significantly less
than if they eat with a partner and it's
not a linear effect but the more people
that are involved in the eating the more
people tend to consume it's like this
behavioral trait we don't really quite
understand oh I understand it clearly I
feel awkward in social situations
especially around people I only see once
a year and one way I make myself feel
better is by
going and eating and eating and going
back to what you're saying about caloric
density you can't just eat sweet
potatoes during the holidays you have to
put a metric ton of butter and
marshmallows on them duh what's the
matter with you and you can't just have
turkey like a cereal killer you have to
have bread doused in Turkey parts and
then turkey juice like yeah you're
asking us to not be human Lane right and
then if you look at you know it's not
just one meal what really what we're
talking about is a series of meals
during the holidays so without really an
actual thesis on this and giving your
listeners some some quick action things
they can do um the first thing is like
stay mindful so that is like if you
decide hey you know what I'm just going
to enjoy this I'm not going to worry
about it that's fine the trade-off with
that is you may gain some body fat you
probably will gain some body fat if you
say if you're somebody who's little more
diet attuned and you say you know I'm
not really worried about that I can take
it off later in the year that's cool no
problem I think for most of us we don't
really have that mindfulness we kind of
go in like we just jump out of the plane
and we kind of hope we got a parachute
on so we'll kind of eat whatever but
then we just kind of send up a hope and
a prayer that you know nothing bad
happens but but but the but the data
tells us the science tells us and this
is you talking to me you've never told
me this before hold out by the way um
that most of us most of the time will
put on 50 to 90% of our weight for the
year in that the last few months and
then we just hit a new plateau and we
just maintained for the rest of the year
and that's how you look up 5 years and
10 years later and suddenly you're 10 or
15 pounds heavier than you were a decade
ago you can trace this back to a big
chunk of that being of course the
knickknacks throughout a week throughout
the year but a big chunk of it is
getting off the rails in the holidays
enjoying yourself having fun at the
holiday parties having fun with family
and friends on multiple parties and then
just holding steady the next year and
then doing it again and then holding
steady the next year and just doing it
again suddenly you wake up and you find
yourself in a tough
spot that's that's correct um and again
like you know we're talking when we talk
about data we're talking about averages
course of course I know there are some
people who say I didn't go right during
the holidays was all doing some of
barbecues for me okay well we're again
we're talking about for the for the
average person that's right
so the actionable things to do I think
the first thing is realize that you know
a lot of your Ramsey listeners are going
to be familiar with keeping a budget
yeah you know uh calories are kind of
you know kind of like a
budget um you know so if for example you
could be great with your your calorie
budget all week but if you go crazy on
the weekends um you know it's still
going to blow your budget right that's
right so you have to be mindful now when
it comes to holidays again we're talking
about usually series of meals so what I
recommend to people is if you know that
there there's an event coming up the
first thing is like if you know you've
got a
dinner don't don't go out to breakfast
that morning right and then don't have a
really heavy lunch like try to keep it
lighter earlier in the day so that you
got you've got some more flexibility in
your budget for later yes then when it
comes to uh your actual meals you know I
don't I food order doesn't really matter
that much some people make a big deal
about it but I would say you know when
you're making your plate at a Holiday
meal you know most people aren't going
to give you a bunch of Guff because I
know a lot of people say why I want my
family to give me hard time and I'm not
eating okay can we make a plate but you
know one try to choose like leaner
proteins so maybe like you know ham is
actually relatively lean uh and then
white meat turkey or a mix of white and
dark meat so you've got some lar
proteins on there you know eat those
first they tend to be a little bit more
satiating can kind of dampen your hunger
a little bit as you head into the more
less filling things um know try to get
some vegetables in there that's also
going to be filling and they're like hey
have some of the foods you want have
some of that you know sweet potato with
butter you know have some of that
stuffing and have some dessert but you
know make you know just tell yourself
one thing I tell people is you just have
one serving okay you can have one
serving feel like a totally normal human
being
and you you know listen to your satiety
cues okay if you feel full there's no
reason to keep eating I think another
thing to keep in mind is liquid calories
and this is where you know one alcohol
consumption is higher during the
holidays yeah so if you know you're
going to be drinking either alcohol or
another form of liquid
calories um those tend to not be uh
those aren't really satiating liquid
calories don't tend to satisfy us so if
you're not a big alcohol person which
you know if you're listening to the show
we probably don't recommend that right
you know maybe focus on your food and if
you do want to have a couple drinks
maybe you're stubbing out saying okay
well you know I'm gonna omit the starch
today or I'm gonna omit the dessert
today because I am going to have a
couple drinks like these are trade-offs
right yes just like if you were doing a
budget okay you know um I want to go
take the wife out to dinner it's going
to cost you know 150 bucks and so that
means you know I'm not going and playing
golf two two days this month something
like that right so you're you're
exchanging out that model um when you
told me that privately just in a private
phone call that model was transformative
for me when I began to think oh I've got
$2,000 I can spend today so it's not a
matter of can I eat that cadburry egg or
not of course you can it's just going to
cost you $600 and you only have 2,000 to
spend and do you want to have that Stak
that your wife is making tonight and cuz
that's going to cost you 1,200 bucks cuz
it's a ribey it it's fantastic um now
you're down to like an apple right so
when I just begin to think of it as a
budget um not in a dramatic way or I
can't do this kind of way dude and I
love the
advice um man when I when I'm
conscientious and I ask myself this
question am I really hungry or am I just
eating because I'm uncomfortable when I
just ask myself that question sometimes
I'm like nope and I'm having that pie
anyway fine my rule is I never fall off
the wagon but sometimes I'll step off
the wagon and roll around in the mud and
climb back onone fine I've got to I got
to pay the piper on that one but I find
myself mindlessly eating around family
and friends and awkward situations I
don't know what to do with my hands so I
just grab something and that idea of
there's a budget and am I really hungry
right now and dude let's eat the
proteins first just as a simple it's not
going to solve all your problems in a
dramatic you YouTuber kind of way but it
does help right it does help fill me up
a little bit and gets me going that way
so dude those are some great great great
tips man
um any last like one truth bomb you can
leave us you've already ruined my uh
Thanksgiving so
thanks and I would say like hey like you
know I'm not telling people you need to
bring up food scale and track your
calories or anything like that like just
you know mindful reasonable portion
sizes if you're somebody that does
struggle with like oh you know I like to
have something in my hand okay you can
have water or you know diet soda you
know God forbid I know there's a lot of
people who don't remind me about this we
don't have time to cover the research
but if you want to take my word for it
the research in human studies where they
control appropriately 80% of studies
show that dieta is perfectly safe and
the 20% that don't are mostly weak
correlations that have a lot of
confounding variables so and if we're if
we're uh using the r white analogy which
is shoot the alligator closest to the
boat if that diet soda even if it's not
ideal if it makes you more comfortable
and you end up like not eating you know
2,000 calories of whatever then that's a
fair that's a great tradeoff dude so hey
I I that's my that's my that has been um
you and I have talked offline using your
carbon app which is the best app in the
game um I've I'm down 10 pounds and it's
not water it's not keto water down it is
it's 60 days slow losing body fat and
one of the things that's kept me in the
game is either Coke Zero or Diet Coke or
Stevia and I know all the diet um witch
Hunters are going to come after me for
that but the data is the data is it the
most healthiest thing no not at all but
does it keep me on the path yes and what
I'm find here's what I'm finding 60 days
in I'm using it less and less and less
right as I make my transition so it's
all the in progress deep Perfection
that's such a big thing yes so many
people feel like they've got to get this
stuff completely perfect the first time
around and they won't let them it's like
I've got it completely clean no cheap
and what ends up happening is when they
ever they get exposed to this kind of
stuff they go crazy because they haven't
known how to moderate and I think one
more thing I I'll add is like you know
if you fall off the wagon so speak no
shame don't beat yourself up figure out
you know have a conversation like why
did this happen what can I do in the
future and then move on um and if you're
going to have fun Foods pick Foods you
really enjoy don't waste it on stuff
that's just for grabbing stuff and one
more thing limit your snacks try to
limit your food to your meals the
research actually very clearly shows one
of the biggest characteristics between
people who lose weight and keep it off
versus those that don't is people who
lose weight and keep it off they on
average don't snack very often because
snacks are less satiating and you tend
to remember them Less in fact you look
at the
research people under report their
caloric intake by about 50% on average
so and by the way they do the same thing
to debt by the way right right right so
it's not that people are lying it's just
that we have rose-colored glasses and
when you if you ask somebody hey what
did you eat yesterday you remember your
meals but you probably don't remember
your snacks the cookies and the Kit Kats
and all that kind of stuff yeah dude
that's that's incredible but dude I'm
Gonna Let You Go dude I'm so grateful
for you get back to working out beef
cake beef cake but dude um thanks for
being my friend um for everybody out
there um please if you're considering
like a like hey I'm going to actually
take this thing serious ly to the next
level and use data carbon app the carbon
app is the best it's what I use it's
what my manager uses Kelly's got it it's
just the best it's the best um it's the
best app and I just recently Lane found
the barcode scanner part of it that I
don't even have to punch it in I can
just scan the barcode with it's amazing
all I have to say is thank you so much
for being a one of the best in the
business and a close friend and a guy
that um helps me through personal
challenges that I have behind closed
doors I'm just really grateful for yeah
so this holiday season be mindful enjoy
yourself have fun
if if you don't want to be around your
family don't just stand there mindlessly
grabbing things and eating them go
outside tell everybody you got to go go
take a nap in the back room sing I don't
know what you got to do but just be
mindful